and that's why i said it's really common
to have a version string in your
manifest file and you keep updating that
version string this can be quite a pain
but it isn't too hard so once we have an
app cache on the user's machine on every
subsequent load the resources will be
loaded from the app cache even when
you're online if it's an HTML resource
with the manifest for example that
master page we started with then we'll
start an async update of that manifest
file at the same time and then continue
loading the rest of the page now if the
manifest has been changed the browser
will update the files in a new
application cache but remember it's
already loaded the page it may be done
loading the page by this point since we
do want to be offline first and we want
to make sure that the page gets loaded
as quickly as possible by the time the
manifest file has been downloaded in the
background the user is probably already
off looking at cat videos out of the
application cache now you can detect
when a new cache has been downloaded and
there's new content available you can
listen for an update ready event on the
window application cache object the
window application cache represents the
application cache system and you can get
things like the status and progress and
tell it specifically to do things like
update the cache or swap the cash out so
you have a lot of control over the
application cache this code here checks
for an update ready event and if there
is actually an update ready then it'll
actually ask the user is it okay to
reload this and if so it swaps the cash
out and reloads